what's your take on this whole beer bug
thing
well i think that initially
there you didn't know what the hell was
going on
so you had to sit there and say okay we
need to look at the data we need to look
at the r
naught value we do that's exactly what i
did for the first three months i'm like
okay let's see the numbers come in let's
see what's going
on yeah yeah that's right but i even
at the height of my concern and this was
way before the normies let's say you got
concerned i'm talking about january
february
of 2020 not not you know april
i was i was concerned then but even back
then when i would go on podcasts i'd say
listen
we need to be concerned with this but
the one thing we
don't want to do is get the government
involved
the government needs to allow people to
make their own decisions
if you want to stay inside you go ahead
and stay inside
what we don't want is the government
coming in and locking people
in their own house at gunpoint yeah or
taking their businesses away
and doing all of these draconian
measures because once they
underst
i was watching the show on uh netflix
basically about
uh psychopath leaders around the world i
can't remember what it was called but
one of the things they said in it that
really stood out is that human beings
love being ruled
and i was like oh [ __ ] i'd like rewind
that for 15 seconds and then play it
back i'm like he's right
people love being ruled like they want a
[ __ ] ruler and
yeah it's just bizarre to me man because
i mean like
it just doesn't feel right you know what
i'm saying like it just doesn't feel
right
yeah i i look around the world today and
um there's there's a lot of opportunity
but there's a lot of things to be
concerned with
and um at some point in time
we're gonna have to pay the economic
fiddler and uh
i don't know how much further they can
kick the can down the road the problem
is
you feel like it's you know it's
supposed to collapse at some time though
right like you're like you know
really like it's still going down the
road well
there's that saying that the market can
remain irrational
way longer than you can remain solvent
yeah you're right
and and and so but see the thing is
though just because they can kick the
can down the road
doesn't mean that you should bet that
way
as though they're going to be able it's
like blackjack you know i when i first
started playing blackjack
i was doing it to help train my kind of
investing mind to think in terms of
probabilities
so you sit there and you've got two
people to blackjack table
let's say i'm paying with someone who
doesn't know what they're doing and
they've got a 19
and they're going to hit because they
think they're on fire right
i'm like oh no no you don't want to do
that that's uh
that that's not a good play you want to
stay here three twos in the last like 10
seconds
yeah like oh george you're just being
you're fear-mongering you know
i'm on fire here and let's say they they
hit and they get a two
you know did they do the right thing or
the wrong thing and i would always argue
they did the wrong thing
uh because if they continue to bet that
way they're going to go bust and it's
the exact same thing today
with buying stocks or certain assets
that are in
massive massive bubbles that yes the
bubble can continue
but it doesn't mean that you're making
the right investment decision
by buying now just because your
portfolio goes up
doesn't necessarily mean that you did
the wrong the right thing
you could have just gotten lucky you
could be a part of a bubble because even
if you think you made money in the short
term if you continue with that strategy
you do not have an edge you have a
negative edge and at some point you're
going to lose
you